ce qu'est le conseil de classe de ce
bouffon et on va avoir les notes voilà
vous allez mettre des notes allant
michel meyer vous aussi acteur michel mr
et vous vous dites voilà la note de
jean-michel hashtag tpm puis j'en ai
acheté pmp jean michel vous donnez une
note à jean-michel alors on va faire une
vidéo récap de tout ce qu'il a dit
pendant cette saison et vous donnera
également mon avis jean-michel sur votre
prestation ça vous fait plaisir à bâle
et toujours alors sachez qu'il ya des
bonnes notes et il ya des notes
catastrophiques
ouais il ya quelqu'un qui vous vous a
défoncé mais je vous dis et pour une
fois le public aussi va pouvoir voter
avec des boulettes de papier c'est à
dire que à la fin de toutes les notes je
vais faire un décompte si vous pensez
qu'il mérite une bonne note c'est de la
pizza 100 français qui mérite une
mauvaise note voulu opérer une bouteille
une boulette de papier l'accord il n'y a
pas de raison que lui mais je n'allais
pas vraiment aux autres années celui qui
aura la meilleure moyenne confondues
nous et attendre un très beau cadeau
voilà pour avoir un cadeau à jouer la
madrague de très beaux cadeaux et j'ai
d'ailleurs un cadeau et d'ailleurs pour
vous à part ça je vous le dis j'aurai un
cadeau pour régis dans un instant à un
cadeau pour mathieu également je me
serais un cadeau pour chacun dans un
instant aucun cas demander s'il va vous
faire extrêmement plaisir je pense
registre non et vous aussi vous avez une
passion en commun vous verrez ça dans un
instant pour le nomme jean michel maire
regardez voix conseil d'état de jean
michel maire jean michel mr récap c'est
ça dans l'émission et c'est parti pour
le conseil de classe 2 enfin michel mr
pour vous servir
jean michel lemaire dans tpm paix c'est
avant tout un chroniqueur d'envergure
toujours classe et élégant dieu
l'accueille bleus pendant quinze jours
mais quoi moi j'ai pris un fou en vendée
c'est simple à cause de sa lourdeur
jean-mi est sorti douze fois du plateau
depuis le début de la saison et surtout
[Applaudissements]
jean michel c'est aussi des gros progrès
en diction cette saison malgré quelques
rechutes chez l'image malheureuse qui
avait été photographié avec emmanuel
micro m
mais plus qu'un chroniqueur jean me est
un sniper très en forme depuis la
rentrée
quand on s'intéresse aux gens et qu'on
aime les gens on discute on est curieux
et encore en boitant essayer de faire
une bonne réflexion et une bonne
intervention passe mon tour
mais j'aime j'aime bien les hommes donc
windows
bref jean michel maire c'est un homme
aimé de tous et de toutes les semaines
il déserta qu'un chroniqueur jamais
chalmers ont vocation à les bisous
justement on a vu delphine et petit
instant que je vous dise comme ça des
filtres avec lui mercredi jeudi vendredi
et a priori elle va venir mercredi 100 g
oui oui des infos que j'ai première
mondiale oui c'est une première mondiale
mais attention je serai là pour veiller
sur elle
attention je suis un ami de rochers qui
ne serait pas là tout le temps 19h51
chéri les notes de jean michel maire on
va démarrer par celui qui met souvent
les plus plus plus bonne note c'est mon
ami maxime alors jean-michel il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire
point positif tu es souvent drôles et
bon camarade tu as oui voilà au négatif
à champ qui va en avoir plus
j'ai dû les sélectionnés tellement j'en
avais tes blagues sont salaces c'est la
soupe à la grimace et je sais que tu
dégages casse pour en trouver et c'est
du passé autant de temps à travailler
car courir les petits tu ne serait le
meilleur élève alors bon c'est un peu
plus avec la tête un peu moins avec le
club
[Applaudissements]
la promo un chapeau
ça va trop loin mais qu'est ce qui lui a
pris une maille écouter d'absurde
islamique
il a marqué trop grassement mais c'est
un avertissement battrait aulas et c'est
ouf
au fond ils échouent alors jean-michel
c'est l'homme amis qui je me dispute le
plus après mon mari pourquoi parce qu'il
a élevé la mauvaise foi au niveau d'un
art parce qu'il a un humour
effectivement monotone et rythme
agréable et d'un top matin à temps
partiel a compris oui il serait pas il a
un humour quoi monothématique matane la
table matin c'est pas là et parce qu'il
baisse atteint d'un ticket qui coula et
parce qu'ils bossent à temps partiel
surtout ça c'est matthew rénale qui
coula non malgré tout ça malgré tout ça
je laime bien parce que au moment où
j'ai le plus envie de le frapper parce
qu'il fait la énième réflexion sur ma
fenêtre qui ressemble grotte de lascaux
ce qui n'est pas vrai ce qui me fait
beaucoup beaucoup rire et que moi j'ai
la reconnaissance du band donc pour tous
a germé les encouragements avec un très
beau un très beau sept sur sept chambres
sénat ou alors moi jean michel vous le
savez il ça fait sept ans qu'il à mes
côtés les voilà il est à ma droite
pendant depuis sept ans et je laime mais
vraiment je laime au il me fait hurler
de rire je suis mais je vous assure
votre préféré c'est mon chouchou c'est
vrai ah oui je laime d'amour franchement
je l adore je n'adore je mettrais avec
lui alors on n'avait pas ce que beaucoup
décisions de gestion que tout ce qu'on
apprécie
mais en plus je trouve que cette année
il a complètement lâché les vannes il
donne tout il donne à fond il ya
plusieurs années mais voilà il a lâché
la rampe lille a plus de chiffres il
s'en fout ça le fait marrer
il est là mais là pour s'éclater
évidemment le point négatif c'est qu'ils
bossent pas mais en fait on s'en fout
que je trouve que même quand il bosse
pas il est drôle pour les poumons et
donc pour tout ça et parce que je
l'aimais je l'aimais 1 800 812 m belaïz
a fondu de christine c'est la troisième
fois que vous parlez noémie j'ai par
contre tu es chef salle alors point fort
sens de la répartie oui d'accord il
apporte beaucoup de piment dans
l'émission c'est frais ça moi ça fait
pas longtemps que je suis de temps en
temps effectivement assez âpre et et
d'huile et j'adore parce que je me marre
j'aime bien parce qu'il ne fait tout le
temps des apartés je suis éclaté de rire
par exemple aussi des appartements
rigole moins ça c'est sûr je dis aussi
devant fille derrière nous et est
souvent ils me van lorsque j'essaie de
faire des vannes et que ça marche pas me
dire à tes points faibles
ton pimont le scot retire pendant
l'émission il est trop souvent en
dessous de la ceinture
l'allemagne 7 sur 10 non c'est quand
même pas mal par tuer le sniper cochon
craquera dégueus cas taux de tp mpk une
mauvaise foi irrésistible tu es cabot à
souhait pour moi car entre aldo maccione
et le côté séducteur vintage et jean
claude dusse vertes années deux partout
mais en fait nulle part ce cas c'est que
même tout cas ce qui est incroyable avec
toi c'est que même quand à la diarrhée
au retour de à paris tandis lâché à ce
qu on est poli une ford racing est
réduit et quant à ta diarrhée verbale
ton âge
franchement moi je pense qu'il est culte
alors moi je te trouve excellentissime
franchement je trouve que tu es le
meilleur autour de cette table et je te
mets un magnifique 3
errance énorme boîte à lille iii la fois
une cohérence et mathieu alors ça me
coûte de le dire pour ravaler sa fierté
parfois mais pour moi aujourd'hui ou le
cas cette saison
tu es le meilleur après moi dans ces
réunionnais qui ont dit pas les choses
attention en revanche tout est plus sage
cette année a pas devenir trop sage
voire chiant comme gainey c'est un petit
risque que tu pourras voir
après pour le reste je vais très honnête
je voulais préparer des vannes fait rire
cyril et tout ça mais en vrai j'ai
surtout s'ils paient trop très ému parce
que du coup je vais pas être drôle jet
juste sincère pour moi tu es le seul ici
qui peut être bon dans les débats qui
peut être bon dans la vanne qui peut
être bon dans le show en général chaque
personne c'est une une je pensais pas
qu'on pouvait avoir une émission en
télévision tu es drôle tu est cultivé
fait partie de mes trois meilleurs amis
aujourd'hui dans ma vie à 44 ans on se
voit toutes les sauces
ondine tous les mercredis ensemble quand
j'arrive chez lui c'est déjà ce qu'il
faut commander pour que ça fasse plaisir
donc voila en gros je m'arrêter là parce
qu'après je me connais ça va couler tu
es quelqu'un de très très très
importants dommages assez logique et
voilà donc
[Applaudissements]
je vais lire mathieu que j'aime aussi la
merci raymond alors moi je suis là
depuis qu un mois et de ce que je vois
horde comme tout le monde un gros gros
soucis de prononciation j'avais pas vu
ça depuis le lycée professionnel de
valmy en cp faire classe que j'avais bat
aurait pu avoir ta ta ta place tu
arrives le dernier tu repars en premier
et tu bosses pas beaucoup alors on l'a
dit à une addiction pour le sexe dans le
transport routier j'ai jamais vu un mec
te donner un camion tu passerais plus de
temps sur les aires de repos qu'à
décharge et met les deux mais je me dis
que en fait c'est quelqu'un de bien
parce que tu es bienveillant quand je
suis arrivé ici il ya un mois je les ai
dit quelqu'un de bienveillant tu m'as
donné quelques conseils parfois et je te
trouve très drôle
alors je te mets un 5,5 avec des gros
encouragements alors mm
on peut dire que tu peux être mon tonton
flingueur un petit peu on rigole
énormément ensemble se marre quand même
bien tu as eu aussi être là quand
j'avais des petits coups de blues et tu
as su être très très bienveillant avec
moi mais la lourdeur l'emportent alors
je t'aimais sera sur dix est réglé il a
été là que vous avez likoud bouzid il
est là quand où et même en laponie
il a été là mais c'est vrai qu'elle
avait un petit coup de blues en laponie
le meilleur film et
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui triste dans ma chambre et et m'a dit
tu veux venir voir un film on a mis les
princesses de brooklyn il a regardé les
princesses de brooklyn avec moi
j'écoutais non j'ai une amie non non aux
jeunes c'est jean-louis noton priant
jamais et j'ai envie de te permets juste
à se placer à terre ils entendent depuis
dix minutes
non c'est pas momonne j'ai beaucoup
changé et syrie cette année jean michel
c'est l'année de la générosité
je vais noter tous les progrès tous vos
progrès et vous avez énormément
progressé vous avez augmenté tous vos
points faibles
c'est simple vous êtes encore plus
inaudible on va fouiller de plus en plus
on vous étiez solide maintenant vous
avez la chasse et au nom de l'amitié
indéfectible qui vous unit à matthieu
delormeau vous êtes plongés dans la
spirale de la fumisterie infernale mais
vous avez un point fort ce point force
et votre sens du collectif
la semaine dernière vous avez été absent
deux jours personne ne l'a remarqué
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour ce sens du collectif cette
solidarité cette abnégation tout ce que
vous apportez et parce que j'ai décidé
franchement d'être généreux je vous mets
la note de référence qui va me permettre
d'étalonner tous les autres chroniqueurs
fait notre très important je vous met un
on va voir la moyenne le service
ionnaires jean michel mr mat détruit
tous 8,8 klaus moyenne 6,8
jean-michel l'ère jean-michel s'assure
qu'on va changer un petit peu la formule
puisque je fais d'émissions en direct
en fait au dernier conseil de classe je
vous donnerai mes notes à chacun
d'accord ou pas d'accord comme ça voilà
temps auraient chacun mais note voilà
que je vous donnerai pas le transmettre
oui voilà